monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
faire confiance et simplifiée l'intitulé
de cette proposition de loi adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale est riche de
promesses
la crise sanitaire a contribué depuis un
an à ériger ses objectif fédérateur au
coeur des attentes des acteurs de santé
exprimer tant dans le secteur de la
santé que dans la mission sur la
gouvernance hospitalière présidée par le
professeur clarisse leur inspiration
c'est légitime et de se recentrer sur
leur coeur de métier le soin le choc de
confiance et de simplification tant
attendue n'est clairement pas et je
regrette au rendez vous de ce texte la
commission
on a déploré le contenu disparates et
sur certains volets chétif son prisme
comme son manque de vision stratégique
cette proposition de loi ne nous a pas
semblé porter au l'ambition pour notre
ciel de santé que ces acteurs de
première ligne au front de l'épidémie
depuis un an sont aujourd'hui en droit
d'attendre
cette ambition appellerait selon moi la
discussion d'un texte à la plus forte
stature plutôt que de procéder par
ajustement surtout la cohérence de
certaines mesures que nous sommes
appelés à voter est mise à mal par un
calendrier de discussions qui précède la
publication d'ordonnancé structurantes
pour l'hôpital issu de wama santé 2022
bien que contraint par les règles de
recevabilité des amendements nous avons
adopté en commission des affaires
sociales une version largement remaniée
de ce texte
nous en avons d'abord recentrer l'objet
en supprimant 10 articles sur 37 pour la
plupart des évolutions de trop faible
portée ou selon nous insuffisamment
préparés c'est notamment le cas de
l'article premier portant initialement
la création d'une profession médicale
intermédiaires auront tour indéfini jeu
engagé je crois sans concertation avec
les professionnels des intéressés
cette mesure n'avait pas sa place dans
un texte prétendants rétablir la
confiance avec les acteurs d'autres
évolutions dans l'émission des
professionnels de santé viennent semer
la confusion dans la logique du parcours
de soins sans compter
tu es une réponse à la demande légitime
de ces professionnels de voir
reconnaître leurs compétences
ici aussi nous avons déploré le défaut
d'une ligne directrice claire nous
allons également rejeté des mesures
engagées dans la précipitation dont les
potentiels impacts collatéraux ne nous
ont pas semblé maîtriser la commission a
ainsi réaffirmé le rôle majeur des
associations dans l'encadrement des
bénévoles intervenant dans le contexte
si sensible des lieux de soins en
refusant les dérives que pourrait
introduire la notion de bénévoles
individuelles concernant l'examen des
dispositions relatives à la gouvernance
hospitalière
je ne peux vous cachez monsieur le
ministre que la du plastique la
déception de la commission est réel la
commission a d'abord déploré un problème
de méthode en constatant d'une part que
la proposition doit traiter de plusieurs
sujets pour lesquels le parlement a très
largement délégué au gouvernement le
pouvoir de légiférer par ordonnances et
d'autre part qu'elle se contentait
malgré l'ambition de son titre de hisser
au niveau législatif des dispositions
réglementaires existantes
elle a surtout regretté que les
propositions portées par le texte soit
pour la plupart d'entre elles des
traductions parfois et du corps et des
recommandations émises par le professeur
clarisse à l'issue de sa mission sur la
gouvernance hospitalière ou par la
concertation du ségur de la santé la
possibilité de former une commission
médico soignante le droit d'option en
matière d'organisation interne
la recomposition du directoire le plan
de gouvernance et de management et même
la lutte contre l'intérim médicales sont
autant de mesures dont l'annoncé produit
certes un effet de courte durée mais
dont la faible envergure selon nous est
une aimant regretté par les acteurs
médicaux et administratifs que nous
avons auditionné la commission face à ce
texte avait deux options dont je ne vous
cache pas que chacune aurait pu se
justifier aux yeux de l'opinion rejeté
en bloc
un texte dont le contenu d'entraîner en
fin de compte que peu de changements
ou tenter de l'améliorer en profondeur
c'est la seconde voie qu'elle a choisie
elle a défendu une position qui me
semble équilibré de prudence mais dans
les sciences à l'égard des groupement
hospitalier de territoire à propos
desquels elle agirait commandé une étude
spécifique à la cour des comptes et dont
elle a tenté de tirer profit elle a
supprimé l'article 4 quater quel est ce
qui met être une véritable provocation à
l'égard des praticiens hospitaliers dans
la vie privée subissait une atteinte
manifestement disproportionnée elle a
fait part de son intérêt pour plusieurs
initiatives qui seront discutés en
séance et qui concerne les inégalités de
traitement entre l'activité libérale
exercée par un praticien hospitalier
d'un établissement public de santé et
l'activité libérale et isa c'est par un
praticien salariés d'un établissement de
santé privé a intérêt collectif
la commission assure tout réécrit les
articles 5 et 6 en exploitant à fond les
opportunités couvrez les dispositions à
peine esquissé par le texte initial de
la proposition de loi est là à sécuriser
les compétences du chef de service afin
d'éviter les chevauchements postiches
vachement possible avec celle des chefs
de pôle elle a permis de satisfaire une
demande très ancienne d'approfondir la
délégation de gestion au sein des
déplacements enfin elle s'est attelée à
l'une des causes du défaut
d'attractivité de vita public pour les
personnels paramédicaux dont mes
auditions montré qu'il était en grande
partie lié à un défaut de représentation
auprès de la direction
elle a ainsi permis l'inscription de la
commission des soins infirmiers de
rééducation et médico-techniques au rang
d organe représentatif d'établissements
puis de santé ainsi que l'élection de
son président par ses membres à travers
toutes ces avancées saluées par les
acteurs le gouvernement a opposé une fin
de non-recevoir peu constructive
consistant à demander par amendements le
rétablissement de l'ensemble des
articles touchante à la gouvernance
hospitalière dans une version identique
à 7
issu de l'assemblée nationale leurs
examens donnera lieu au cours dé de nos
débats à des explications plus
détaillées
la commission des affaires sociales
fidèle aux positions tenues au cours de
ces travaux a favorablement accueilli
les initiatives de tous bords politiques
qui servait la construction d'un hôpital
public - contre 1 et plus soucieux
d'assurer à ses personnels
l'attractivité qui lui fait aujourd'hui
tant vous faut nul doute que le texte
qui sortira de nos débats répondra
davantage au mot et attentes de nos
soignants notre tâche est encore
pourtant loin d'être achevée au problème
désormais structurel de l'amandon
résigner à l'hôpital public par nos
gouvernements successifs
la commission a une nouvelle fois
rappelé qu'aucune mesure législative ne
pourra durablement se substituer aux
revalorisations salariales qui
s'imposent l'urgence est là impérieuse
mais face aux mauvais génie français de
la réforme il semble que les évidences
les plus criantes reste encore ignorées
pour autant le souci qu'a montré la
commission de tirer de ce texte le
meilleur qu'elle avait à offrir lui
permet d'en présenter aujourd'hui au
sénat une version si ce n'est parfaite
du mois a nettement amélioré la
commission vous demande donc en
conséquence d'adopter cette proposition
de loi dans le texte qui ressortira de
ces travaux
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président nous passons
à la discussion de discussion de la
motion tendance à opposer la question
préalable pour cette motion préalable la
parole est à madame laurence cohen et
les membres du groupe communiste et
républicain écologistes qui ont déposé
cette motion
c'est donc madame cohen qui la défend
pour dix minutes
monsieur le président madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
notre groupe a fait le choix de déposer
cette motion tendant à la question
préalable car nous sommes opposés aux
orientations de cette proposition de loi
d'ailleurs les soignantes et les
soignants non ans sans vent debout
contre la plupart des mesures qu'elle
contient monsieur le ministre vous avez
utilisé la proposition de loi de la
députée stéphanie rist pour compléter
voire ajouté
certaines mesures du ségur de la santé
l'impact de cette ppl sera lourd de
conséquences pour notre système de santé
est bien éloigné de la volonté de
simplification afficher ainsi il s'agit
notamment de renforcer l'échelon des
groupements hospitaliers et territoriaux
qui devient encore davantage la
référence alors même que le rapport de
la cour des comptes d'octobre dernier
est plutôt mitigé de même cette ppl
offre une place prépondérante aux
gestionnaires et technocrates
ceux là même qui ont conduit l'hôpital
public à l'asphyxié parallèlement où
paradoxalement cette ppl va autoriser le
bénévolat à l'hôpital ce que mon
collègue député pierre dharréville à
comparer à juste titre à une réforme du
belize ation des activités associatives
notre groupe a décidé de déposer cette
motion car nous nous opposons non
seulement sur le fond aux mesures qui
sont en deçà des attentes et des besoins
mais également sur la forme le
gouvernement ayant travesti cette
proposition de loi
en véritable projet de loi et en ayant
convoqué une procédure accélérée
cette méthode al'avantage pour le
gouvernement de s'exonérer d'une étude
d'impact et d'un avis du conseil d'état
ce qui laisse de fortes incertitudes sur
les conséquences de ce texte que nous
refusons le plus grave est ce décalage
qui existe entre ce texte et le vécu des
professionnels de santé et du médico
social
comment oublier que ce texte qui se veut
le prolongement du ségur de la santé
c'est suite à la première vague de covin
19 et surtout à des mois de mobilisation
de collectif et de syndicats des
personnels et puis contradictions
supplémentaire bien ce que ce texte
affiche la volonté d'enrichir le ségur
il ne contient en réalité que seulement
5 des 38 propositions qui y figurent
alors qu'il faudrait s'attaquer aux
racines du malaise
des personnels soignants manque de
moyens pilotage comptable gestion calqué
sur le privé ce texte prolonge une
vision libérale de l'hôpital public en
assumant l'introduction des règles du
management privé dans le secteur public
dans la lignée du new management public
il veut renforcer la vision gestionnaire
et managériale de l'hôpital
cette conception détourne le système
public de sa fonction première le soin
et vise à rapprocher l'hôpital public du
fonctionnement des cliniques privées au
mépris de l'histoire du service public
hospitalier des valeurs portées par ses
agents et des services rendus aux
populations respectant l'égalité de
toutes et de tous
quelle que soit son origine sociale et
son territoire derrière l'argument des
contraintes organisationnelles se
dissimule l'autonomie de gestion et
l'autonomie de moyens des établissements
de santé
l'autonomie n'est donc qu'un paravent
pour justifier sans doute pour plus tard
une baisse supplémentaire des dépenses
de l'état ou de la sécurité sociale de
plus en renforçant l'autonomie des
hôpitaux vous forcer la main aux
réorganisation des services et des
métiers administratifs et techniques
il faut au contraire renforcer l'égalité
d'accès aux soins
plutôt que de casser le cadre national
du service public de santé en prenant
modèle sur l'autonomie des universités
qui a aggravé la mise en concurrence des
établissements et encourager le
financement privé
la crise semble donc vous fournir un
prétexte pour aller plus loin vers la
déréglementation vous ne faites vous ne
le fait pas au hasard vous le faites
pour pousser le plus loin possible des
logiques gestionnaires et technocratique
qui ont contribué à affaiblir l'hôpital
public
cela va encore alimenter la mise en
concurrence entre structures et
favoriser la gestion pyramidale et
centralisée des hôpitaux par exemple
départ d'un directeur d'hôpital pourrait
être le père et ex affaires de cet
hôpital
au bout du compte une annexe de
l'hôpital support du groupement
hospitalier territorial alors que les
bilans financiers démontrent l'échec des
groupes hospitaliers territoire vous
décidé d'accélérer ce que vous appelez
l'intégration et l'installation de mes
gars j'ai acheté pourtant les personnels
rencontrés lors des mines
breux déplacement dans les hôpitaux et
les ehpad publics ont toujours remis en
cause et continue de le faire
ce pilotage à distance des
superstructures randonnée de la tripe
l'attractivité aux professions de santé
et du médico social passe par la
revalorisation des métiers
l'augmentation salariale mais également
par le partage des pouvoirs et donc des
décisions
la réhabilitation des chefs de service
est totalement amoindri par le maintien
des pôles
pourquoi se maintient alors que la
majorité des professionnels à l'image du
collectif inter hôpitaux demande leur
suppression critiquant la bureaucratie
qu'il génère a contrario ce que vous
appelez la gouvernance doit redonner à
chacune et à chacun sa place et
s'appuyer sur deux piliers
premier pilier la fin des politiques
d'austérité avec un objectif national
des dépenses d'assurance maladie à la
hauteur a minima de l'évolution
naturelle des dépenses second pilier
l'instauration d'une véritable
démocratie sanitaire avec une
représentation plus importante de
l'ensemble des professionnels médicaux
administratifs techniques des étudiantes
et étudiants internes de médecine des
usagers et des élus locaux
totalement absents des prises de
décision rien de tout cela ne se
retrouve dans le texte
à part une mesure effectivement à
l'article 9 enfin mais il y aurait tant
à dire
il manque dans ce texte des éléments
fondamentaux pour un meilleur maillage
de proximité donc une offre de soins à
égalité pour l'ensemble des territoires
ainsi les centres de santé sont
totalement oubliés
pourtant d'après les chiffres du conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins
le nombre de médecins ayant au moins une
partie de leur activité en centre de
santé a presque doublé entre 2010 et
l'attrait du salariat et de l'exercice
regroupé attire de plus en plus les
jeunes médecins et malgré les tentatives
de certains de les maintenir dans le
sacro-saint exercice libéral il y a
indiscutablement un développement de la
médecine salariée notamment chez les
généralistes
il est donc nécessaire de renforcer
l'attractivité des centres de santé qui
permettent l'accès aux soins non
programmés que les médecins libéraux est
abandonné depuis le décret mattei
supprimant les gardes
me des week-ends et des jours fériés
c'est d'autant plus nécessaire que selon
l'association des maires de france et
les bergs euros la désertification
médicale s'accélère et les habitantes et
les habitants des zones rurales sont
celles et ceux qui accèdent de moins en
moins aux hôpitaux ainsi en 2019 7,4
millions de françaises et de français
habitait dans un désert médical soit 11
% contre 5 2007 millions en 2016
le manque de médecins est une des cause
fondamentales de l'accélération de la
désertification médicale
madame busin y avait répondu par la
suppression du numerus clausus dans les
études de santé mais sans moyens
supplémentaires accordés aux universités
sans investissement immobilier et sans
revalorisation du tutorial du tutorat
cela revient la situation actuelle de
stagnation du nombre de médecins formés
selon emmanuel vigneron géographe de la
santé plus on est loin mon 1 de
formation et moins il ya de médecins
pourtant la crise sanitaire de lakovic
19 démonte l'enjeu d'investir dans
l'éducation à la santé dans un maillage
territorial d'accès au soin
malgré deux éléments positifs la
suppression de l'article important sur
la création de professions médicales
intermédiaire vilipendé de tous et le
maintien de plusieurs articles pour
renforcer les prérogatives des sages
femmes contribuant ainsi à une meilleure
reconnaissance cette profession libérale
vous comprendrez mes chers collègues que
nous ayons déposer cette motion de rejet
car nous sommes en désaccord avec la
conception générale de ce texte
malgré notre appétence pour le débat nos
désaccords de son avec ce texte rend de
l'adoption de nos amendements très
hypothétique le plus grave ce ministre
et qu'aucun enseignement n'ait été tirée
de la pandémie que nous vivons depuis
près d'un an et qui ne s'éteint toujours
pas vous continuez à inscrire des
mesures dans le droit fil des réformes
qui ont conduit notre système de santé
là où il en est aujourd'hui loi hpst de
roselyne bachelot loi santé de marisol
touraine ou encore ma santé 2022 d'agnès
busin avec un suppléant supplément la
casse du cadre national du service
public de santé
mes chers collègues avec cathy apourceau
poly
nous avons entendu des critiques
virulents
contre son texte en contre ce texte en
commission
nous avons même entendu de la colère
monte de tous les bancs nous vous
invitons donc par conséquent en tout cas
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
prétendent défendre le service public de
santé et qui prétendent refuser la case
du système hospitalier de voter notre
motion c'est le moment
au lieu de toujours remettre à plus tard
ce que l'on peut faire le jour même je
vous remercie
merci quel est l'avis de la commission
même la présidente merci l'avis de la
commission est un avis défavorable car
l'adoption de cette motion mettrait un
terme à nos débats et nous souhaitons
débattre à vis du gouvernement
j'ai une demande d'explications de vote
de madame poncet mange
merci madame la présidente je vais
intervenir sur les deux motions je
prends les ports personne n'est dupe
cette proposition de loi hétéroclite
incomplète dépourvue de souffle de
méthode et de cohérence est un énième
projet de loi gouvernemental dissimulé
en prêtant du travail parlementaire pour
accélérer les réformes en contournant
l'avis du conseil d'état et l'étude
d'impact alors que cette proposition
prétend compléter le ségur de la santé
quant aux dimensions non financières
touchant notamment à la gouvernance et à
la démocratie sanitaire qui ont donné
lieu à de nombreuses contributions de
nombreuses rencontres suite au mouvement
social
cette marche forcée s'explique par le
peu de prise en compte des enseignements
tant des rapports de la cour des comptes
ou du professeur clarisse que surtout de
la mobilisation de ce qui s'est passé
pendant la pandémie des longues
négociations du ségur de la sauter il
s'agit donc pour le gouvernement de
passer en force en prenant le risque
d'avoir simulé la concertation consentis
il est vrai sous la pression de la
mobilisation des professionnels de santé
pour pousuivre la même logique celle qui
fragilisent encore et toujours notre
système de santé est affaibli l'hôpital
public
qui en pleine pandémie perd encore des
lits enfin le parlement n'est pas
respectée voir instrumentalisée et la
commission sociale du sénat n'a pu dans
le cadre de la procédure accélérée
valablement travailler d'autant que nous
sommes en attente des ordonnances en
lien avec certaines mesures de cette
proposition de loi le sénat ne peut
accepter ce déni du travail
parlementaire
il va de notre responsabilité mes chers
collègues de ne pas le tolérer
cette proposition de loi fait l'objet de
deux motions tendant à opposer la
question préalable et demandant le
renvoi en commission en cohérence avec
les protestations issus pourtant de tous
les bons le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire vaudra favorablement les deux
motions dont nous partageons beaucoup
des arguments je vous remercie
merci yat il d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
crc sommes sur cette question préalable
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable à vis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement j'attends le
scrutin et que je serai
cueillie 27 voix pour 254 voix contre 1
elle n'est donc pas adoptée
nous passons l'addition discours de la
motion tendant au renvoi en commission
monsieur bernard jomier les membres du
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 70 tendant au
renvoi la commission du texte en
discussion la parole et matata madame
monique lubin pour la motion et pour dix
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues certaine
manière de légiférer installé par
l'actuelle majorité gouvernementale
était déjà très contestable avant
l'irruption de lakovic 19 dans nos vies
la crise sanitaire les rend encore plus
difficilement supportable
a fortiori quand il s'agit de réformer
dans la précipitation le système de
santé comme c'est le cas avec la
présente proposition de loi elle est
très insatisfaisante sur le fond elle
témoigne de la constance du mépris
exprimé par l'exécutif aussi bien à
l'encontre du parlement que des
partenaires sociaux ce sont ces constats
qui motive la motion de renvoi en
commission que je présente aujourd'hui
au nom du groupe socialiste écologistes
et républicains du sénat
il y a en effet beaucoup à redire sur le
traitement du parlement et du travail
législatif dont témoigne la genèse le
contenu et les modalités d'examen de la
présente proposition de loi en premier
lieu
nul n'ignore que si le texte qui est
soumis à discussion aujourd'hui est
marquée au show de l'initiative
parlementaire il est avant toute chose
une commande du gouvernement la
proposition de loi visant à améliorer le
système de santé par la confiance et la
simplification est censé traduire dans
notre droit
les mesures non budgétaires annoncées
dans le cadre du ségur de la santé il
aurait été opportun qu'elle fasse
l'objet d'un projet de loi et non d'un
texte d'origine parlementaire
il s'agit ici pour l'exécutif d'obtenir
la transposition dans la loi d'un
certain nombre des dispositions du ségur
de la santé mais en soustrayant aux
contraintes qui sont liées à
l'élaboration et à l'examen d'un texte
d'origine gouvernementale
en procédant de la sorte le gouvernement
se libère de deux obligations
le texte a fait l'objet ni d'un avis du
conseil d'état ni d'une étude d'impact
pourtant le respect que nous devons
soignant aurait exigé qu'un tel texte
soit non seulement sécuriser
juridiquement par un avis de cette
instance n'est qu'ils fassent aussi
l'objet d'une étude d'impact afin que
ses conséquences soit analysé les études
d'impact ne sont décidément pas le fort
de ce gouvernement
on se souvient de celle qui accompagnait
le projet de loi réforme des retraites
étrillé par le conseil d'état cette
proposition de loi se veut pourtant
ambitieuse est par conséquent
susceptible d'impacter lourde
un système de santé dont nous avons plus
que jamais besoin qu'ils fonctionnent
efficacement
je m'interroge donc sur le sens des
circonstances et l'appréhension de la
gravité de ses responsabilités et de ses
obligations par la majorité elle
improvise sans méthode et sans rigueur
la réforme d'un système de santé dans le
bon fonctionnement est aujourd'hui plus
que jamais impératif
c'est pourtant le moment de faire bien
les choses ou de ne pas les faire
nous n'y sommes pas les sénateurs du
groupe socialistes écologistes et
républicains estiment que les
dispositions que porte cette proposition
de loi ne sont pas inscrits dans le bon
véhicule législatif
il pose d'emblée problème à l'absence
d'avis du conseil d'état et dans quel
public s'ajoute à l'encontre de ce texte
est une fois de plus sa conception
mépris de toute véritable concertation
avec les parties prenantes
ce n'est pas un hasard si la majorité
des professions concernées par ces
propositions de loi sont vent debout
contre des dispositions qui ont soulevé
une profonde indignation des syndicats
et des professionnels de santé et un
rejet unanime de la part de l'ensemble
des acteurs la suppression de son
article premier est à ce titre
emblématique pourtant initialement
création d'une profession médicale
intermédiaire
la fronde qu'il a provoqués a conduit à
sa piteuse évolution à l'assemblée
nationale en demandes de rapports
relatifs à la création d'une profession
médicale intermédiaire pour finalement
être purement et simplement supprimée
dès le stade de l'examen en commission
au sénat
ce manque de concertation relève d'une
méthode et traduit une conception très
descendante de la politique
elle joue des tours gouvernement car
elle se manifeste notamment par un
recours accru aux ordonnances et aux
mesures réglementaires qui en khl est
excessivement sur le domaine du
parlement la commission des affaires
sociales n'a ainsi pas manqué de
souligner le paradoxe consistant pour le
gouvernement à promouvoir des
dispositions qui ont aussi fait l'objet
d'ordonnancés et de mesures
réglementaires des dispositions déjà
modifié par la loi d'accélération et de
simplification de l'action publique
publié il n'ya même pas deux mois et
demi le sont par ailleurs de nouveau
dans cette proposition de loi
il en va de même pour les dispositions
concernant le recrutement des praticiens
hospitaliers et la gouvernance des
hôpitaux comme les dispositifs de
coopération renforcée il était pourtant
au coeur du décloisonnement censé être
porté par la loi de juillet 2000
neuf relative à l'organisation et à la
transformation de notre système de santé
comment les professionnels peuvent
s'emparer des modalités d'exercice
coordonner et de coopération même chose
pour les instances de gouvernance de
l'hôpital où faute de vision globale le
gouvernement s'enlise au milieu du gué
aujourd'hui alors même que la plupart
des ordonnances concernées n'ont pas
encore vu le jour
le gouvernement via sa majorité
parlementaire accroît le flou en
revenant sur des dispositifs non encore
appliquées
non seulement le parlement a été
dessaisi de ses prérogatives en 2019
mais il l'a été pour rien si l'on en
croit le résultat quant au gouvernement
il n'est toujours pas au clair sur sa
conception même de notre système de
santé
le manque de sérieux dans la démarche
est encore attestés par le temps imparti
pour l'examen de ce texte à l'origine
cette proposition de loi qui se veut
pourtant ambitieuse et qui exigeait
l'examen de plus d'une trentaine
d'articles dont certaines dispositions
sont susceptibles de changer la
gouvernance des hôpitaux ne devait être
discutée quand une demi journée
comprenant son erreur le gouvernement a
demandé une modification de l'ordre du
jour en dernière minute afin de laisser
une demi journée supplémentaire aux
débats ce changement contraire n'a
cependant rien de satisfaisant
on nous demande de travailler dans la
précipitation sans pouvoir nous appuyer
sur une pourtant nécessaire enquête
publique ni sur un avis du conseil
d'état tout aussi nécessaire
cette absence d'éléments justifierait à
lui seul de siéger plusieurs jours pour
pallier les incohérences du texte et
éviter l'adoption de mesures qui
risquent de déstabiliser notre système
de santé au plus mauvais moment
de fait de l'assemblée nationale au
sénat cette proposition de loi très
succincte lorsqu'elle a été déposée par
ses auteurs au bureau de la chambre
basse a d'ores et déjà fait l'objet d'un
travail de réécriture extrêmement
important témoignant du grand manque de
rigueur rédactionnelle juridique de
certains articles
ce travail de réécriture a été aussi
bien l'oeuvre du gouvernement que des
rapporteurs
c'est dire la préparation de ce texte
procédez ainsi est irresponsable et
irrespectueux à l'égard du travail
parlementaire et encore une fois
pu être l'occasion d'un débat et d'une
réforme de la gouvernance hospitalière
que la pandémie de la police 19 arrondi
plus que jamais nécessaire mais le choix
du véhicule législatif du temps très
restreint à un parti pour les débats et
d'une procédure accélérée nous empêche
de les mener sereinement
il est ainsi flagrant que cette
proposition de loi sans fil conducteur
ne soit qu'une tentative incomplète
d'assemblage de mesures mal articulées
entre elles il n'y a pas de vision
globale de ce que devrait être notre
système de santé rénové pas de projet
pour lui nous ne pouvons pourtant pas
nous payer le luxe de voter des
dispositions redondantes insatisfaisante
créant de nouvelles contraintes dont les
conséquences n'ont pas été préalablement
évalué sur les 33 mesures que comporte
le ségur de la santé seulement 5 sont
reprises dans la proposition de loi
elles ne font l'objet que de 6 des 42
articles que comporte le texte après son
passage à l'assemblée nationale c'est
bien mince pour un texte qui était censé
traduire le volet non financiers des
conclusions du ségur de la santé
l'article 10 de la proposition de loi
correspond ainsi à la mesure 3 2 ce
ségur qui vise à mettre fin aux abus
dans l'intérim médical la mesure 7 du
ségur est relative au renforcement du
déploiement de la pratique avancée
elles permettent à des infirmiers de
réaliser des missions élargies par
rapport à leurs champs de compétences
initiales afin de répondre aux
évolutions de l'organisation des soins
cette mesure était prévue à l'article
1er qui a donc été changée en demande de
rapport après l'examen du texte à
l'assemblée nationale est supprimée lors
de l'examen en commission par le
rapporteur la mesure 18 reprises à
l'article 5 de la proposition de loi
viserait à donner plus d'autonomie aux
services des hôpitaux en matière de
gestion et d'adaptation de leur
organisation
il s'agirait de revenir à des unités
plus concrète les services d'oncologie
bout de cardiologie
plutôt que de se reposer sur des
superstructures la mesure 19 est liée à
la précédente
les hôpitaux ne seraient plus obligés de
s'organiser en pôles d'activités
réunissant plusieurs services la mesure
22 du ségur quant à elle viserait à
mieux associer les soignants et les
usagers à la vie de l'hôpital
elle trouve sa traduction dans plusieurs
dispositions du texte dont la
possibilité de fusionner les commissions
médicales d'établissement et les
commissions de soins infirmiers de
rééducation et médico-techniques des
mesures comme la mesure n 7 du
ségur ils ont à lutter contre les
inégalités en santé ou encore la mesure
31 visant à renforcer l'offre de soutien
psychiatriques et psychologiques sont
absentes de la présente proposition de
loi la mise en place d'un numéro
national de prévention du suicide 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
le recrutement de 160 psychologue
supplémentaires dans les centres médico
psychologiques
le fait de donner accès à des
consultations du psychologue ambulatoire
serait pourtant nécessaire dans une
période où la santé mentale des français
est mise à mal par la pandémie de covile
19 et ses conséquences enfin les
dispositions concernant les sages femmes
si elles vont dans le bon sens aurait pu
faire l'objet d'un texte à part je
conclurai mon intervention en soulignant
que ce texte manque cruellement d'une
vision globale n'avons pas suffisamment
de recul pour nous prononcer sur des
mesures dont les effets n'ont rien n'ont
pour l'instant pas pu faire l'objet
d'une quelconque évaluation nous ne
pouvons pas légiférer sans les sans
visibilité
par conséquent nous demandons un renvoi
du présent texte en commission afin de
nous donner les moyens de l'examiner
dans les délais plus approprié et pour
avoir plus de visibilité sur les
ordonnances en cours merci madame la
sénatrice sur cette motion de renvoi en
commission quel est l'avis de la
commission
merci madame la prison que le renvoi en
commission ne répondrait pas aux
objectifs souhaités de légiférer en
disposant d'une plus grande visibilité
notamment sur les ordonnances en cours
enfin cela ni travail important que nous
sommes parvenus à conduire dans l'est
certains réduits sur ce texte dans la
commission a adopté une version je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure en séance enfin au
début largement remaniée en outre même
en connaissant le contenu des
ordonnances en cours de publication
nous pourrions empiété par nos
amendements sur le champ de ces
habilitations en application de
l'article 38 constitution enfin je doute
qu'un délai supplémentaire nous
permettent de le
et toutes les limites que nous
connaissons à ce texte en particulier
l'appréciation de son périmètre
resterait le même il resterait contrat
de la même façon en nous empêchant donc
dès lors de compléter ce texte d'autres
volets intéressant au final je crains
que l'effet concret de l'adoption de
cette motion se limite juste à retarder
l'avancée de nos travaux et pour toutes
ces raisons la commission a donné un
avis défavorable
quel est l'avis du gouvernement la
présidente madame la sénatrice monique
lubin
je voulais juste revenir sur sur le fond
on va avoir le débat et enfin j'espère
qu'on aura l'occasion d'avoir des
banners dans cet hémicycle et il est
évidemment légitime
sur la forme je retiens vous avez parlé
de mépris vis à vis du parlement et
vis-à-vis des partenaires sociaux
méprisé du parlement on aime la
sénatrice moyens croyez le ou non mais
c'est une initiative parlementaire de a
à z de la première à la dernière ligne
de ce texte c'est une parlementaire
qu'il a écrite et qu'il a même écrite
avant que les accords du secure est
était mis en place et été examinés
mépris du sénat le texte a été transmis
au sénat
la première semaine du mois de décembre
c'est à dire il ya un peu plus de deux
mois
j'ai le sentiment de la sénatrice que le
parlement a été en le corps respecté
après vous on peut considérer que les
pprl père opposition parlementaire sont
une bonne ou une mauvaise option dans la
mesure où elle nous prive de fait une
haie du conseil d'état mais enfin c'est
la constitution qui l'autorisent
et si je vous disais que j'étais
défavorable aux propositions
parlementaires pour le coup je prépare
je ferais preuve d'un mépris ce qui
n'est pas mon cas
et quand vous dites mépris vis-à-vis des
parts des partenaires sociaux les
accords du ségur c'est la première fois
depuis des décennies qu'on a un accord
majoritaire chez les soignants chez les
médecins
chez les non soignants chez les
étudiants un accord majoritaire
la sénatrice qui va de force ouvrière
unsa cfdt
j'ai pas l'impression que les
partenaires sociaux a été méprisée sans
quoi il n'aurait peut-être pas apposé
leur nom et leur signature en bas des
accords qu'ils ont renouvelé leurs 11
février quand nous avons étendu le
périmètre du ségur aux personnels et
c'est d'ailleurs avec les parlementaires
de tous bords nous avait sensibilisé aux
personnels du secteur médico-social
rattacher un établissement de santé
publique
et enfin la mission clarisse qui est une
mission très grande qualité et une
demande on s'est beaucoup inspiré la
députée stéphanie rist est une mission
qui a mobilisé des dizaines de milliers
de soignants qui ont répondu et qui fait
consensus avec des communiqués de presse
de la plupart des conférences des
collèges des syndicats attestant du fait
que ces mesures sont portés donc vous
pouviez vous n'êtes pas d'accord mais
encore une fois le mépris j'ai du mal à
le voir donc un avis défavorable bien je
suis saisi d'une demande d'explications
de vote de madame cohen oui merci madame
la présidente
effectivement cette motion de renvoi en
commission et est un élément important
pourquoi parce que pour toutes les
raisons qui ont été données et les
raisons qui ont été données par ma
collègue monique lubin rejoignent pour
beaucoup les critiques que nous avons
fait nous au groupe communistes
républicains citoyens écologistes et qui
nous ont conduit à faire une question
préalable parce qu'on le voit bien il ya
des critiques qui sont formulées et puis
finalement et bien la conclusion de la
majorité de droite de la commission
c'est de dire mais on va débattre
or on sait très bien que le débat est
extrêmement restreint on sait aussi très
bien que les mesures qui sont prises
aujourd'hui sont absolument dans la même
logique que les politiques qui ont
conduit notre système de santé là où il
en est alors je sais bien qu'en dix ans
un certain se sentent offensés mais
c'est la réalité des faits la réalité
des faits aujourd'hui c'est une
situation des hôpitaux qui est en
surchauffe et les mesures du ségur qui
ont été soit disant pour répondre aux
revendications des personnels n'ont pas
répondu à l'attenté de ses personnels
pourquoi parce que il y a effectivement
à prendre la problématique non seulement
de la revalorisation des métiers mais
également aussi du fait d' arrêter de
fermer des lits et d'embaucher et de
rendre attractives les carrières or ça
ça n'est pas pris à la hauteur de ce
qu'il faudrait et quand on critique au
niveau de l'hémicycle quand on essaye
de dialoguer avec le gouvernement le
gouvernement et sachant et les autres ne
savent pas et bien ça c'est pas source
de pouvoir faire avancer
finalement une politique qui va répondre
aux besoins des populations et à la
tente des personnels alors on n'a pas
beaucoup d'illusion sur le fait du
renvoi de cette de cette demande de
renvoi en commission puisque c'est
rejeté par la majorité
lr delà de la commission mais nous
allons quand même voté par principe
parce que nous pensons que les dés sont
pipés et que le débat véritable n'a pas
lieu et que les mesures à la hauteur des
besoins ne sont pas prises merci pour
une explication de vote monsieur daumier
merci madame la présidente je vais pas
rentrer et non plus dans le débat sur le
fond mais trois points la commission
nous dit ça n'aurait pas d'intérêt en
termes de calendrier de renvoyer en
commission
c'est devancé les desiderata du
gouvernement si nous déposons une motion
de renvoi en commission
c'est pour prendre le temps d'avoir
connaissance que les ordonnances qui
concerne directement ce texte soit
publiée et donc de pouvoir étudier ce
texte plus tard en mars puisqu'il a
annoncé la publication pour le mois de
mars
et mon dieu ça donnera le temps au
gouvernement qui encore aujourd'hui
déposer des amendements qui pour parler
des diététiciennes pour parler des
préparateurs en pharmacie et cetera si
les ces sujets sont aussi important de
les inclure dans le texte parce que pour
le moment ils sont irrecevables ces
amendements et donc ça montre bien un
préparation de ce texte et la nécessité
de délibéré de façon éclairée donc en
ayant connaissance du texte de ces
ordonnances seulement on anticipe le
fait que le gouvernement veut passer en
force et que si la motion était adoptée
eh bien ils convoqueraient la commission
et demande à la commission de se renier
immédiatement il nous ferez siéger
vendredi samedi dimanche que sais-je
mais moi je ne suis pas souvent dans mes
vote opposition supposée du gouvernement
et je veux croire qu'il reste un peu de
sagesse au gouvernement pour constater
comme nous qu'il est qu'il est temps de
reporter l'examen de ce texte après la
publication de ces ordonnances
deuxièmement la concertation et l'accord
il a été sur le ségur monsieur le
ministre pas sur 7 pp
sur cette ppl les auditions qu'elle a
proposé des rapporteurs et celles
auxquelles nous avons auditionné ont
montré un désaccord général sur le
contenu de ce texte et donc nous ne
voyons pas là les bases d'un texte qui
fait un minimum consensus en tout cas
large accord au sein des professions de
santé que ce soit à l'hôpital que ce
soit hôpital public où que ce soit dans
le secteur de vide donc pour toutes ces
raisons nous estimons nous avons plus
besoin de temps et qu'il est plus
raisonnable de renvoyer ce texte en
commission
bien j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public le
scrutin est ouvert
monsieur renvoi en commission a
recueilli 91 voix pour et 2 154 voix
contre elle n'est donc pas adoptée dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à madame véronique guillotin
pour l'europe et rds et cinq minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cherche
mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
hve par son titre de nombreux espoirs
améliorer le système de santé par la
confiance et la simplification la crise
sanitaire qui a frappé notre pays de
plein fouet a mis en lumière les forces
de notre système de soins
mais on a également relevé les
faiblesses pendant la langue ce décrue
de la première vague de contaminations
gouvernement annoncé l'initiative
intéressante de la tenue du ségur de la
santé qui doit permettre une évolution
tant attendu une part dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui pose l'objectif de
constituer le versant non financiers des
conclusions du ségur enrichi des
propositions du rapport clarisse sur la
gouvernance de l'hôpital
pour autant le véhicule législatif
utiliser la préparation concomitante des
ordonnances par le ministère de la santé
compliquer l'exercice et nous prive
d'une étude d'impact et d'un avis
du conseil d'état pour autant la grande
majorité du groupe rds la majorité tout
en entendant les raisons du dépôt de la
question préalable et de la demande de
renvoi en commission n'a pas voté ces
deux motions car pour suivre les débats
sur des sujets majeurs tels que la
gouvernance des hôpitaux les
coopérations l'attractivité des
carrières ou encore l'intérim permet
permettra j'en suis sûr d'enrichir le
texte
et c'est dans cet état d'esprit que nous
nous inscrivons j'évoquerai en premier
lieu les coopèrent et les protocoles
locaux de coopération le texte de la
commission par son article premier
revient au cadre juridique issu de la
loi santé de juillet 2019 et permet
ainsi de les étendre aux professionnels
de santé travaillant de manière
coordonnée et hors établissement cette
disposition répond aux besoins d'une
médecine plus coordonnée au bénéfice du
patient en ville comme à l'hôpital
la faible démographie médicale mais
aussi l'explosion des maladies
chroniques l'aspiration des jeunes à
trouver un équilibre entre vie
professionnelle et vie privée
l'appétence pour l'exercice en équipe
pluridisciplinaire implique absolument
est nécessairement l'évolution du champ
des compétences des professionnels de
santé
nous aurons à examiner de nombreux
amendements concernant les sages-femmes
et des auxiliaires médicaux certains
vont plus vont plus ou moins loin mais
une philosophie doit nous guider est
demeuré améliorer fluidifier le parcours
du patient sans le détricoter le médecin
généraliste et et doit en rester le
pivot le segura également mis en
évidence l'existence bien antérieure à
la crise qu vide d'une perte
d'attractivité des métiers de la santé
les hôpitaux et structures
médico-sociales d'ailleurs peine à
recruter
la revalorisation légitimes des salaires
ne permettra pas seuls d'y remédier de
bonnes conditions de travail plus
d'effectifs dans les services une
gouvernance moins technocratique et plus
médicalisée une cm aux missions et au
rôle renforcé des recrutements
simplifiées sont en grande partie les
constats et propositions du ségur et du
rapport clarisse dont certaines seront
examinés dans cette ppl ce qui n'est pas
abordée par contre et qui sont des
préoccupations fortes des fédérations
c'est la symétrie des contraintes et des
rémunérations entre les carrières
médicales publiques prix
et ou associatives et les freins à
l'exercice d'un médecin sous différents
statuts
aussi je proposerai en partie d'y
remédier par la réintroduction de deux
articles dont l'article 14 bis qui
permettra au delà de la remise d'un
rapport de ne pas enterrer trop
précocément cette problématique
s'il est un sujet dont la crise a relevé
les limites c'est bien celui de la
gouvernance des établissements l'article
5 consacrée à l'organisation interne
reste heures la fonction de chef de
service sans l'opposer mais plutôt en
complémentarité avec le chef de pôle
l'organisation des pôles doit absolument
rester une possibilité pour chaque
établissement
la création de chefs de service et de
chefs de pôles adjoint améliorer encore
le fonctionnement de l'hôpital le groupe
rdse a déposé des amendements en ce sens
comment parler d'organisation sans
évoquer les j'ai acheté installé à
marche forcée leur fonctionnement est
hétérogène
un rapprochement imposer des
établissements n'est pas souhaitable
mais il mérite d'être à la fois
encourager et sur la base du volontariat
l'article 9 de la proposition de loi
ouvre le directoire de l'hôpital en
prévoyant la possibilité pour le
directeur de désigner des personnalités
qualifiées
c'est à notre sens une bonne chose je
regrette cependant l'exclusion des
étudiants au sein de au sein de ce
directoire
je terminerai en évoquant les abus de
l'intérim médical qui pénalise
lourdement à la fois les finances et
fonctionnement de l'hôpital
ce n'est plus acceptable aujourd'hui et
malgré la volonté du gouvernement 2010
est d'y mettre un terme force est de
constater que le problème perdure il est
devenu urgent de mettre fin à ces
pratiques que je qualifierais de
scandaleuse et permettent enfin
l'application du plafond des
rémunérations
l'hôpital ne peut pas et ne doit pas
être une zone de non-droit dans laquelle
certains professionnels importe
imposerait des exigences financières
déraisonnable pour conclure cette
proposition de loi se présente comme un
patchwork de mesures qui s'explique par
le destin régulier singulier de ce texte
penser avant la crise sanitaire puis
saisit opportunément comme le moyen d'y
intégrer quelques mesures du ségur et
tout ce qui ne rentre pas dans champs
des ordonnances suffira-t-elle à
satisfaire les attentes
en tout état de cause le groupe rdr et
serveurs à son vote en fonction de
l'évolution des discussions et aimer le
jeu
que les mesures consensualiste du ségur
et du rapport glac clarisse puisse
trouver ici une traduction législative
ans merci la parole est à madame cathy
apourceau poly pour l'europe cee
mais dame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
notre groupe a déposé une monde une
motion tendant à la question préalable
car nous pensons que ce texte ne peut
pas être améliorée
sa philosophie globale est contraire au
service public national de la santé que
nous défendons depuis plusieurs années
comme l'a rappelé ma collègue laurence
cohen
derrière les mots simplification et
confiance il faut lire management public
des hôpitaux et autonomie renforcée pour
gérer l'austérité mais qui est en
réalité celle du gouvernement est pour
le moins hétéroclite mais non dépourvue
de cohérence l'affaiblissement du
service public plutôt que d'investir
massivement et durablement dans notre
système de santé
ce texte propose de ronger les murs
porteurs de l'hôpital après un secure
raté vous nous proposez une loi fourre
tout qui ne pourrait pas en rien aux
attentes des soignants ni même des
usagers depuis trente ans les politiques
d'austérité ont entraîné la fermeture
des hôpitaux des maternités des centres
de santé publique des caisses
d'assurance maladie
l'éloignement des services publics à
créer une véritable rupture d'égalité
notamment pour les plus fragiles
à l'heure des débats sur le séparatisme
votre politique d'affaiblissement des
services publics renforcent le
séparatisme financier qui met son argent
au luxembourg vous renforcez le
séparatisme économique qui licencient
après avoir bénéficié des milliards
dette publique
enfin vous renforcez le séparatisme
social de celles et ceux qui n'ont pas
les moyens d'accéder aux soins
cette proposition de loin de loi donne
l'illusion aux personnels hospitaliers
qu'en contrepartie du renforcement de
l'autonomie des hôpitaux ils pourront
dégager des économies suffisantes pour
sortir des baisses des dotations
quelle déception quel mensonge alors que
certains
services n'ont même plus les moyens
d'acheter des couvertures pour les
malades ni de renouveler le matériel
vétuste
cette proposition de loi va encore
aggraver la situation en renforçant
l'autonomie des hôpitaux vous accélérer
la mise en concurrence des
établissements publics de santé entre
eux comme si la concurrence avec les
établissements privés lucratifs et non
lucratif ne suffisait pas vous créer une
profession d'auxiliaires médicale en
pratique avancée
vous avez certainement oublier
l'activité professionnelle des
infirmiers anesthésistes diplômés d'état
qui se livrent depuis de nombreuses
années à un exercice de pratiques
avancées mais je suis certaine que vous
allez revoir votre copie que vous aller
les écouter
ne pensez vous pas qu'il est temps
monsieur le ministre de répondre aux
véritables besoins des personnels
médicaux et paramédicaux
c'est urgent nécessaire
arrêtez avec ces lois qui ne sont que du
bricolage à saxe où les personnels ont
besoin de considération de recrutement
de revalorisation salariale
d'amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail
c'est une des solutions à la pénurie
alors plutôt que de renforcer le pouvoir
des chefs de service il faut renforcer
la démocratie sanitaire et permettre une
meilleure représentation de l'ensemble
des usagers des personnels et étudiants
en santé pour leur permettre de prendre
part aux décisions
nous avons déjà eu l'exemple des
universités qui a suivi le même chemin
le renforcement de l'autonomie des facs
s'est traduit par une baisse du budget
de l'enseignement supérieur de 10% entre
2008 et 2018 tandis que le nombre
d'étudiants a progressé lui de 20%
l'accélération de l'intégration des
hôpitaux dans lé groupement hospitalier
territoire prévu à l'article 7 ne répond
absolument pas aux revendications des
personnels hospitaliers
elle éloigne encore plus les réponses
aux besoins en santé des usagers votre
dispositif a hanté intérim se retourne
contre les directeurs d'établissement
qui devront privilégier les fermetures
de services ont recours à l'intérêt
ou s'ils veulent éviter les sanctions
financières c'est pourquoi il convient
au contraire de sanctionner les
entreprises de travail temporaire qui ne
respectent pas le plafond de
rémunération nous proposons de rétablir
les gardes de nuit du week-end et des
jours fériés en indemnisant correctement
contrepartie les médecins qui effectuent
ces astreintes sur la question du
handicap
enfin vous répondez à tous les besoins
en mettant en place une plateforme
numérique unique d'accès au droit
pourquoi pas il est indéniable que
l'accès au droit pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et les aidants est
un vrai parcours du combattant
mais où sont les mesures pour les
établissements médico sociaux
où sont les revalorisations salariales
les décrets pris à l'automne on exclut
ces personnels du ségur de la santé de
la même manière une négociation pour la
fusion des conventions collectives du
secteur est en cours avec le risque de
dégrader encore les conditions de
travail pour les personnels
un numéro vert ou une plate forme c'est
bien mais cela ne doit pas cacher la
misère
pour toutes ces raisons notre groupe
votera contre cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
élisabeth doineau pour le groupe union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales mes chers collègues la
crise sanitaire a révélé les limites de
notre système de santé
elle nous a permis aussi de reprendre
conscience du travail remarquable
réalisé au quotidien par tous les
professionnels qui participent à notre
parcours de santé
sommes nous à la hauteur de cet
investissement clairement répondons-nous
à leurs attentes légitimes
lancé en mai 2000 20 à l'issue du
premier confinement le ségur de la santé
a suscité beaucoup d'espoir
cet effort inédit est incontestablement
une belle avancée en revanche beaucoup
nous diront avec amertume qu'il ne
s'agissait pas du ségur de la santé
mais plutôt du ségur de l'hôpital public
jour après jour les parlementaires ont
été et sont encore interpellé par des
professionnels qui se retrouvent exclus
des revalorisations sans en comprendre
les raisons
dernièrement ce sont les personnels de
certains établissements médico-sociaux
qui nous ont appelés en fin d'année nous
étions 64 sénateurs a interpellé le
ministère de la santé monsieur le
ministre pour qu'une réponse adaptée
soit trouvé avec l'ensemble des
professions oubliés du ségur
aujourd'hui nous examinons la
proposition de loi notre collègue député
madame stéphanie rist visant à améliorer
le système de santé par la confiance et
par la simplicité
elle vise à concrétiser les mesures non
budgétaires du ségur de la santé signé
par les partenaires sociaux comme ça l'a
été rappelés avant d'entrer dans le
détail de l'examen du texte
je souhaite vous faire part de quelques
remarques générales alors que nous
examinons cette proposition de loi
composé de 35 articles dans le cadre
d'une semaine gouvernementale une seule
et unique demi-journée lui étaient
initialement consacré sa était aussi
rappeler cela nous promettait donc un
examen au pas de course
je sais de lui donc l'ouverture de la
journée de jeudi pour examiner dans de
bonnes conditions ce texte une
proposition de loi ne permet ni étude
d'impact ni avis du conseil d'état
je le regrette nous le regrettons et
c'est d'autant plus regrettable que nous
sommes sur des questions fondamentales
j'ai personnellement un autre sujet
d'inquiétude c'est le peu d'enthousiasmé
de la part de 16 de ce que j'ai entendu
lors des auditions les demandes
d'entretien et le nombre d'amendements
proposés corroborent ce sentiment d'un
manque total d'adhésion à cette
proposition
je le regrette les uns se sentant
injustement écarté les autres pour le
mois déconcerté attention nous ne sommes
pas loin d'observer
une réelle des motivations des
professionnels celui-ci notre rapporteur
alain milon qui a mené un important
travail d'audition auquel j'ai essayé de
participer le plus possible et c'est
justement mon témoignage que je disais
il ya quelques instants du peu
d'enthousiasmé que j'ai rencontrés au
cours de ses auditions
enfin cette proposition de loi se veut
la traduction de la partie non
budgétaires des conclusions du ségur
mais force est de constater qu'elle
n'atteint pas cet objectif puisque
seulement cinq des 33 mesure du ségur de
la santé se retrouvait dans le texte de
commissions de l'assemblée nationale
j'entends les propos de son auteur
nombre de mesures attendues par les
professionnels de la santé relève du
niveau réglementaire et des ordonnances
prévues dans le cadre de la loi ma santé
2022 et ne figure donc pas dans ce texte
aussi nous sommes en droit de nous
interroger sur l'intitulé de cette
proposition de loi vise t-elle
réellement améliorer notre système de
santé par la confiance et la
simplification
j'en doute s'il ya urgence à redonner de
l'attractivité aux carrières au sein des
hôpitaux publics et cette urgence les
sentiments d'injustice et de frustration
ne cesse de monter sur le terrain il
faudra un jour y répondre
je m'arrête là pour ce qu'il est ce
qu'il en est des considérations
générales
jean vient désormais aux articles de la
proposition de loi
je commencerai par ce que je considère
comme des avancées bienvenus il s'agit
du chapitre 2 relatif à l'évolution des
professionnels de la profession de
sage-femme et de certains auxiliaires
médicaux
si les articles 2 et suivants n'engage
pas de révolution ils sont autant de
bouffées d'oxygène pour les professions
concernées et surtout pour les patients
il conviendrait d'amplifier ce mouvement
aussi une fois n'est pas coutume je ne
partage pas la position de notre
rapporteur qu'ils me pardonnent sur
l'article 2 k qui s b qui permettait aux
sages-femmes d'adresser leurs patients
par médecin spécialiste sans pénaliser
les
patiente en termes de remboursement par
l'assurance maladie des frais de soins
je ne crois pas que cette mesure
induisent une confusion dans la logique
du parcours de soins coordonnés
articulée autour du médecin traitant
c'est au contraire une mesure de
simplification du coup du parcours des
patientes qui seraient bienvenus c'est
d'ailleurs l'objet de ma proposition
nous le savons le temps de la grossesse
est un temps à part dans la vie d'une
femme les sages femmes n'ont donc pas
vocation à se substituer aux médecins
aussi dans un objectif de simplification
du parcours de santé et d'un meilleur
accès aux soins
j'ai déposé plusieurs amendements pour
amplifier les skis aperçue dans ce
chapitre 2 mais j'attire la vigilance du
ministre nous ne pouvons étendre
indéfiniment le champ d'intervention de
ces professionnels sans améliorer leur
statut
concernant la mesure phare porté
initialement par l'article 1er je
partage en tout point l'analyse de notre
rapporteur introduit une nouvelle frappe
de professionnels de santé ne peut se
faire sans l'assentiment des principaux
concernés
cela n'a pas été le cas dont acte le
chapitre iv relatif à la gouvernance des
établissements publics de santé suscite
beaucoup de réactions
à vrai dire il ya tellement eu de
réaction que c'était assez en brouillant
à vrai dire beaucoup d'acteurs de
proximité ne comprenait pas la non
reprise des préconisations du professeur
clarisse je remercie notre rapporteur
d'avoir respecté ce travail unanimement
salué en récrivant ses articles dans la
même dynamique l'article 5 modifié par
d'autres commissions et bienvenue par la
notion de service les consensus chez les
professionnels enfin nous ne pouvons que
souscrire à l'objectif d' associer
davantage le personnel soignant à la
gestion de l'hôpital notamment par le
biais de l'élaboration du projet médical
dont la finalité est de répondre aux
besoins de santé de la population
pour conclure cette proposition de loi a
fait naître de nombreux sentiments
ambivalents oscillant entre l'espoir et
la déception la mesure contenue dans le
texte ne parviennent pas à se hisser à
la hauteur des ambitions et des attentes
bien les
tim de celles et ceux qui donnent le
meilleur d'eux-mêmes et plus encore en
cette période particulièrement
éprouvante le sénat apporte un certain
nombre d'améliorations salutaire aussi
le groupe union centriste votre a
favorablement le texte ainsi modifié
merci la parole était monsieur bernard
jomier pour cinq minutes et gisti
républicain par marc rich samedi
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission affaires sociales me sera
porteur chers collègues je crains que ce
texte ne simplifie pas plus qu'ils ne
créent davantage de confiance à la
sortie de son passage en commission au
sénat
neuf articles ont été supprimés le texte
a un peu dégonflé sans atteindre la
taille toutefois usuels d'une
proposition de loi
le rapporteur a procédé à un important
travail de réécriture sur de nombreux
sujets complexes et pourtant absolument
essentiel pour notre système de santé
mais nous ne pouvons que déplorer le
rejet notre motion de renvoi en
commission qui aurait pu nous octroyer
le temps nécessaire pour effectuer un
travail à la hauteur en pleine
conscience notamment des ordonnances en
préparation vous choisissez un examen
monsieur ministre qui est bâclée or nous
considérons que les soignants mobilisés
depuis un an pour faire face aux
différentes vagues de l'épidémie
méritait mieux
je m'attarderai brièvement sur quelques
articles qui ont particulièrement retenu
notre attention l'article premiers
supprimés par le rapporteur visait à
créer une profession médicale
intermédiaire entre infirmiers et
médecins sans en détailler les modalités
techniques et juridiques
face au mécontentement général il est
devenu une simple demande de rapport
dressant un état des lieux de la mise en
place des auxiliaires médicaux en
pratique avancée des protocoles de
coopération les mêmes protocoles de
coopération que l'article 1 bis visait à
étendre avant donc dettes évaluées
chercher la logique
l'article 1er un bees donc qui dans sa
version initiale n'était pas plus
compréhensibles étant les protocoles de
coopération à tout le champ de
l'exercice coordonnées alors même que
les dispositions votées dans la loi
santé 2019 sont encore à peine appliquée
le chapitre ii lui apporte quelques
dispositions attendue et réclamée par
les sages-femmes depuis longtemps c'est
très bien mais d'autres professions
nécessite encore notre attention
les infirmières et les infirmiers par
exemple dont le rôle dans l'offre de
soins demeurent insuffisamment reconnues
nous proposons des amendements pour que
leur soient octroyés de nouvelles
compétences concernant la gouvernance de
l'hôpital l'intention de l'article 5 est
positif puisqu'il a pour ambition de
réaffirmer le rôle des services et les
chefs de service
nous pensons en effet qu'il constitue
une unité pertinent dans la prise de
décisions d'organisation et de mise en
oeuvre de l'offre de soins etc les
réformes successives de les eaux de
l'hôpital ils ont trop éloignés des
instances décisionnelles
mais l'article 5 procède-t-il réellement
à ce changement de cap
je ne crois pas et je ne crois pas que
nous puissions promettre aux personnels
hospitaliers le changement qu'ils
attendent
si nous nous ne posons pas clairement la
question de la répartition des
compétences entre les pôles d'activité
et les services dans la même logique
nous défendons une place plus importante
donnée à la parole des paramédicaux
représenté au comme au sein de la
commission des soins infirmiers de
rééducation et médico-techniques la
gestion de la crise de la coved à
l'hôpital a souvent permis de mettre
autour de la table la direction les
médecins et des soignants dans le cadre
d'un véritable travail collectif pour
organiser la prise en charge les verrous
financiers ne sont pas les seuls à
passer au second plan pendant cette
crise le verrou de la verticalité
souvent bureaucratiques qui caractérise
la prise de décision à l'hôpital a lui
aussi sauté temporairement
c'est dans ce sens et donc dans celui de
la reconnaissance de l'implication des
soignants dans la prise en charge
quotidienne des patients qu'il nous faut
travailler c'est pour cette raison que
nous nous opposons disposition l'article
6 qui prévoit dès que des fusions de la
commission médicale d'établissement de
la commission des soins infirmiers de
rééducation et médico-techniques nous
sommes convaincus qu'il faut au
contraire conforter une plus grande
autonomie à la commission des soins
infirmiers et par conséquent ne pas
permettre une telle fusion l'article lui
lui propose d'introduire la possibilité
pour un établissement de santé sur son
initiative de déroger un organisation
des soins en pôles d'activité ou adoptés
gouvernance son directoire cmu ou
commission des soins infirmiers il nous
paraît surprenant que plusieurs articles
précédents s'efforce de modifier la
gouvernance de l'hôpital vers plus de
place aux services aux soignants pour
permettre dans cet article de pouvoir y
déroger
de plus il ne correspond à aucun souhait
exprimé du terrain et ne satisfait
aucune demande formulée ni dans le
rapport clarisse ni dans le rapport
notât enfin la proposition de loi
s'achève sur un énième article décevant
sur le land
cap il n'y at il pas d'autres ambitions
du ségur de la santé pour le secteur
médico social que la commande d'un
rapport et l'instauration d'une
plateforme en ligne venant s'ajouter un
numéro vert déjà en place et dans tout
le monde s'accorde à dire qu'il ne
remplit pas son rôle
monsieur le ministre il nous est
difficile de marquer une grande
insatisfaction voir une colère alors que
nous démarrons l'examen de ce texte
vous avez refusé d'inscrire le sujet de
la gouvernance dans les discussions du
ségur et vous présenter un texte qui
comprend plus d'une dizaine d'articles
et non des moindres sur la gouvernance
dans une proposition de loi censé mettre
en oeuvre les mesures du ségur
la vérité c'est que seulement quatre ou
cinq mesures du ségur se retrouvent
réellement dans ce texte
la vérité si vous avez refusé
d'organiser des états généraux de
l'hôpital public qui ont permis de
traiter valablement les enjeux de
l'organisation de la gouvernance de
l'hôpital
la vérité c'est que l'on attend toujours
le ségur de la santé publique
c'est que vous nous demandez de voter
une loi dans la confusion sur merci
merci la parole est un la baronne et
stéphane ravier non-inscrits pau 3
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la crise du
corner virus aurait eu un mérite celui
d'avoir mis en lumière l'état d'extrême
fragilité pour ne pas dire de
délabrement dans lequel se trouvaient
nos hôpitaux conséquence d'un abandon
délibérée des pouvoirs publics qui ont
considéré la santé les français comme un
luxe qu'il convenait de réduire au nom
d'une gestion financier en scène le
résultat de la proche précieux
prioritairement financière de la santé
nous le connaissons le deuil des
familles la fatigue et la colère d'un
personnel médical dans le courage ne
suffit plus encaisser la mutation du
serment d'hippocrate en discours d'
hypocrite de la part de leur ministre de
tutelle successifs mais le mal ne se
résume pas à l'état catastrophique dans
lequel se débat l'hôpital public
ils frappent tous les domaines liés à la
santé au manque de places et
d'équipements et de personnel dans nos
hôpitaux
s'ajoute à la pénurie de médecins en
ruralité la sueur administrations les
numerus clausus est étriqué et dépasser
la disparition de notre production
nationale de produits pharmaceutiques et
pas seulement les masques chirurgicaux
mais aussi vaccins et médicaments
l'abandon par l'état des chercheurs et
les entreprises innovantes
les restrictions budgétaires sans vision
de long terme imposée par bruxelles
or dans un pays qui se veut l'un des
plus riches et les plus accueillants les
plus protecteurs la santé de ses
citoyens ne devraient pas être considéré
d'abord comme un coût mais comme un
investissement
ce projet de loi on est encore bien
éloigné les leçons de la crise sanitaire
qui est loin d'être terminée ne sont
manifestement pas tirer se préparer au
pire pour nous pour éviter de le vivre
de le revivre encore n'est toujours pas
à l'ordre du jour
continuer à refuser le principe de
précaution est une erreur et refuser la
souveraineté est donc l'indépendance et
sanitaires une faute
cette proposition de loi je retiendrai
soutiendrez néanmoins la revalorisation
de la profession des sages femmes
d'abord parce qu'elles sont les garantes
d'un accompagnement personnalisé
optimale pour les femmes et les nouveaux
nés
elle met en place les meilleures
conditions pour la natalité française
dans un contexte de crainte en l'avenir
elles suivent et donc rassure les femmes
pendant leur grossesse à sur
l'accouchement et accompagne la mère et
l'enfant pour les soins de postes
natalité je soutiendrai dans ce texte
l'élargissement de leur périmètre
d'activité trop souvent considérée comme
une profession paramédicale
les sages femmes doivent pouvoir varier
leurs prérogatives médical et obtenir
une rémunération à la hauteur de leur
diplôme de leur statut et surtout de
leurs responsabilités mais le salaire ne
fait pas tout il n'efface pas
l'épuisement
tout cela ne servira à rien si l'on
n'augmente pas le nombre de sages femmes
le mouvement populaire une femme une
sage-femme pointe l'insuffisance des
effectifs qui conduit à une prise en
charge des patientes qui dans bien des
cas n'est pas satisfaisante
alors oui nous souhaitons adapter les
compétences des sachants me demande
aujourd'hui mais sachons dans les
prochaine loi de finances leur accorder
toute leur place pour une revalorisation
de leur statut en accroissement du
personnel et des moyens mis à leur
disposition notamment pour leur
formation dans l'ensemble alors que tout
devrait être revu de fond en comble ce
texte présenté dans la précipitation
manque cruellement d'ambition
pourtant le savons les économies d'hier
nous coûter très cher aujourd'hui et pas
seulement financièrement malgré ses
insuffisances mais devant l'urgence jeu
voiture est en faveur de ce texte
merci la part avec un monsieur daniel
chassaing pour le groupe des
indépendants
et pour cinq minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre le président de la commission
sur apportant mes chers collègues le
ségur de la santé apporter des aides
importantes d'autorisation de
revalorisation rattrapage pour 8
milliards pour les salaires et une aide
de 19 milliards pour l'investissement
cette proposition de loi veut y apporter
des précisions concernant les freins de
management la gestion de l'hôpital est
en ville
l'important c'est de débattre d'apporter
effectivement des améliorations de ce
texte le sénat mal faire et j'aurais
salué le rapporteur qui a oeuvré dans ce
sens la création de l'exercice
d'infirmer en pratique a lancé
accessible après trois ans d'une bonne
initiative
déjà le médecin généraliste et bien
second départ être infirmière dans la
surveillance des maladies chroniques
pour le diabète survient des
anticoagulants d'insuffisance
respiratoire rénale troubles
psychiatriques ou encore l'état général
ces pratiques sont déjà bien intégrés
dans les maisons de santé avec lesquels
il affirmé à les médecins travaillent de
concert avec les pharmaciens dans le
cadre de la cisa je ne suis pas
favorable favorable ce stade à la
création d'une nouvelle profession
médicale intermédiaire privilégie le
dispositif de pratiques avancées en
incluant des infirmiers anesthésistes
comme le propose mon collègue alain marc
en revanche vous ne vaut mieux
travailler avec les pharmaciens qui
contrôle et en donnant ce conseil les
patients sont des acteurs de premier
plan et de prévention y participent aux
vaccinations font des substitutions de
médicaments mais ne sont pas toujours
nous semble pour l'instant autorisé à
prescrire un médicament pour les six
types ni même demandé un examen du
rythme commençons par améliorer
l'existant plutôt que de créer
une nouvelle profession le pharmacien
est un maillon essentiel dans
l'organisation des soins
les officines sont ouvertes du lundi au
samedi et j'en profite pour réagir aux
propos un peu méprisant d'une élue du
bas rhin nous devons au contraire
applaudir les pharmaciens pour leur
dévouement et leur sérieux en ce qui
concerne l'évolution des compétences des
sages-femmes
je ne vois pas médicalement d'obstacles
à prescriptions d'arrêts de travail au
delà des quinze jours je suis favorable
la prescription de dépistage des hits et
s du conjoint à l article 3 propose de
simplifier le recrutement des praticiens
hospitaliers en effet il faut donner aux
établissements la possibilité d'être
plus réactifs en simplifiant les
procédures qui sont trop lourdes et
revaloriser encore les sévères l'article
5 vise à revaloriser l'ass et m
la place du chef de service
effectivement ça a été dit il faudra
préciser son rôle par rapport aux chefs
de pôles ainsi que associer le personnel
les internes des paramédicaux au projet
de l'hôpital l'article 7 visait à
renforcer l'intégration des j'ai acheté
par le prisme des directions communes
cela permettrait avec l'accord des élus
locaux des cm2 mettre en place une
véritable vision du territoire
cette direction commune entre un
établissement de même j'ai acheté me
semble être une solution la plus
efficace la plus adaptée pour mettre en
oeuvre un projet médical partagé avec
l'établissement support en visant à
faire du département lorsque c'est
possible
l'échelon préférentiel d'organisation de
juger acheter je sortir je soutiendrai
la maman de mon collègue 20 premiers
noms ville visant à renforcer le rôle
des élus locaux scène et conseil de
surveillance
l'article 7 concernent la création d'un
service d'accès aux soins non programmés
en améliorant la demande de soins en
amont des urgences en dirigeant les
patients vers un professionnel de santé
pour une consultation sans rendez vous
nous devons mettre en place ce
dispositif sur l'ensemble du territoire
et lorsqu'il n'y a pas de centre
hospitalier ce service
devra reposer sur les msp et d'une spi
de garde avec l'essai pts l'article 10
vise à lutter contre les abus de
l'intérim médical faut savoir que
établissements sont dépendants de ce
recours pour assurer la continuité des
soins notamment dans certaines
spécialités et c'est une amélioration de
la revalorisation des gardes que les les
intérims baisseront monsieur le ministre
à faire confiance et simplifié pourrait
s'appliquer au département à qui il
serait confiée la totalité du maintien à
domicile personnage et par personne
handicapée avec la gestion des siad et
ainsi la coordination des intervenants
seraient facilités avec un seul numéro
d'appel et pourquoi pas d'ailleurs le
budget soit dans les ehpad le c ur de la
santé je les dis à apporter des
améliorations mais le ciel avait été
oublié et nous espérons que le
médico-social du handicap recevra
également rapidement cette augmentation
pour concluant ce mini je rappellerai
l'importance de d'amplifier les
formations de médecins des soignantes et
d'infirmières il ya un manque très
important ville en établissement des
emplois non pourvus en ehpad cette ppl
je finis avec les amendements du sénat
pour prend une aberration pragmatique
dans le fonctionnement de l'hôpital
nous y sommes favorables et nous
espérons monsieur le ministre quel
seront retenus dans les prochains
budgets
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur madame la présidente de la
commission mes chers collègues depuis de
très nombreuses années l'hôpital public
est en souffrance manque de moyenne avec
son corollaire de fermetures de postes
fermetures de lits reconnaissance
salariale insuffisante complexité de
l'organisation en traînant une carence
d'attractivité chronique pour nos
hôpitaux
et pourtant la réponse du personnel à la
pandémie a été et est encore remarquable
et admirable dans ce contexte
particulier
alors que le ségur la santé et le
rapport extrêmement documenté et riche
en préconisations du progrès soeurs
clarisses ont fait naître un certain
espoir
nous examinons aujourd'hui une
proposition de loi qui malgré son titre
attractif n'est que déception et
frustration comme l'ont déjà souligné
mes collègues la forme interroge cette
ppl en ne reprenant que peu de
dispositions du ségur la santé cinq sur
33 ne répond en rien aux attentes du
monde médical et hospitalier
et pire encore elle crée une insécurité
juridique et des et compréhension
quelle sera la place cette ppl alors que
les ordonnances promise avec la loi ma
santé en 2022 agnès buzyn n'ont toujours
pas été publiés
on est donc bien loin d'une
simplification équipe usée
cette ppl comporter au départ pas moins
de 42 articles
ce clip est pour le moins inhabituel
donc beaucoup auront été supprimés ou
entièrement réécrit dès la première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale
preuve de ce même préparation maintenant
sur le fond est ce que cette proposition
de loi s'attaque véritablement aux
problèmes de l'attractivité de nos
hôpitaux publics
tient-elle compte des remontées de
terrain et de la vraie vie des
personnels et des usagers
absolument pas ce texte va aller au
contraire un nombre important de sujets
sans apporter de réponse de fond ou de
vision globale
il ne fait qu'effleurer les
préoccupations majeures du monde
hospitalier
loin de renforcer l'attractivité des
carrières hospitalières et la
valorisation des personnels soignants le
texte sous couvert de simplification
propose même des mesures contre
productive tels que le bénévolat
individuel ou la possibilité pour un
directeur de j'ai acheté de créer un
poste de praticien hospitalier la
création d'un service d'accès aux soins
aurait également mérité un travail plus
approfondi entre l'hôpital et la
médecine de ville et en particulier avec
les maisons pluridisciplinaires de santé
ou les établissements de soins primaires
la pandémie a mis également en exergue
la question de la démocratie sanitaire
quelle leçon en tire le gouvernement
aucune dans ce texte
assurément
les professeurs les professionnels
hospitaliers pendant la première vague
ont estimé que si l'hôpital avait su
gérer il devait à la fois bien sûr à
l'hyper mobilisation de l'ensemble des
personnels
mais à quel prix mais aussi au fait que
la santé avait été érigée en grandes
priorités et le carton de l'exécution
budgétaire remisé au second plan quelle
leçon tire le gouvernement aucune n'a
non plus pire il s'enferre dans la
vision de l'hôpital entreprise avec la
création d'un projet managériale que
nous avons supprimé en commission
grâce à landemont un amendement de notre
groupe c'est l'article 11 qui a été
supprimé certes il existe quelques
propositions intéressantes je pense en
particulier ce qui concerne les sages
femmes ou les kinés mais l'ensemble
provoque un sentiment de déception et de
frustration qui risquent de démobiliser
l'ensemble du personnel hospitalier
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
nous aurions dû examiner ce texte aussi
désordonnée et au champ d'application
aussi large avec pour le moins un peu
plus de recul et un travail plus
approfondi
nous aurions dû aussi attendre les
ordonnances du gouvernement et mieux
travailler le chant de l'application
reste on nous le devons à nouveau à nos
soignants et à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens usagers de notre système de
santé qui sont eux aussi extrêmement
négative madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues en cette fin d'après midi on
nous demande brièvement examiné une
proposition de loi qui voudrait être la
traduction du ségur de la santé les
défis sont de taille qui nous appellent
à redoubler d'efforts à l'issue du ségur
il s'agissait je cite le communiqué de
presse du ministère de la santé de faire
tomber les murs entre l'hôpital la
médecine de ville les établissements
médico-sociaux luttait avec une énergie
nouvelle contre les inégalités de la
santé donner plus de voix aux soignants
dans la gouvernance des établissements
de santé mieux tenir compte des enjeux
environnementaux mettre le numérique au
service là sont et de tous et tout cela
dans l'intérêt supérieur des patients et
de leur santé
est-ce que la proposition de loi que
nous etc
non en procédure accélérée répond à cet
objectif qui est de traduire dans notre
droit les objectifs du ségur
malheureusement non ce texte ne répond
pas son ambition initiale
les mesures proposées pour l'hôpital
public est largement insuffisante la
pandémie a pourtant mis en exergue les
dysfonctionnements de l'hôpital et
l'expert l'exaspération des soignants
qui sont épuisés se sentent
insuffisamment pris en considération nos
infrastructures sont souvent vétustes et
le nombre de lits reste insuffisant
depuis le début de la pandémie les
sujets essentiels comme la formation et
l'organisation de la médecine de ville
sont complètement éludé
concernant l'aspect financier nous
sommes tous conscients de la nécessité
de revaloriser les salaires des
personnels médicaux et paramédicaux
il est impératif d'avoir des salaires
décents au regard des responsabilités de
l'engagement des soignants
d'autre part il est urgent de favoriser
l'installation de médecins sur
l'ensemble du territoire et de résorber
les déserts médicaux
mais cette traduction du ségur de la
santé ne propose aucune mesure forte
en ma qualité de médecin et de
parlementaires je regrette ce décalage
entre les mesures annoncées lors du
ségur et de la santé et cette
proposition de loi aux mesures est
disparate
monsieur le ministre cette proposition
de loi aurait pu être l'occasion d'une
vraie réforme
mais la teneur de ce texte est la
procédure accélérée ont considérablement
amoindri son ambition de plus le
périmètre la proposition de loi initiale
et les règles de recevabilité des
amendements qui procède de la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
n'ont pas permis au sénat d'enrichir ce
texte pour répondre aux attentes des
professionnels santé et des patients
malgré tout le rapporteur et les
commissaires aux affaires sociales ont
pu regagner ce texte pour l'améliorer
dix articles sur 37 ont été supprimés
notamment l'article 1er qui dans sa
version initiale proposée la création
d'une profession médicale intermédiaire
en d'autres termes un médecin au rabais
faisant l'unanimité contre elle cette
proposition a été abandonnée dès
l'examen par l'assemblée nationale pour
être remplacé par une demande de rapport
à remettre au parlement dans un
donnant que nous avons supprimé
supprimer également l'article prévoyant
l'intervention de bénévoles à titre
individuel dans les établissements
publics et privés de santé en dehors du
cadre associatif les compétences des
sage femmes en matière de prescriptions
d'arrêts de travail et d'examens de
dépistage et de traitement et élargi je
me réjouis aussi que la lutte contre le
recours abusif à l'intérim médical était
amélioré les attentes des soignants et
des français sont importantes ce texte
improvisé insuffisant dont nous ne
saisissons pas les objectifs risque de
les décevoir une nouvelle fois néanmoins
nous allons tâcher d'améliorer cette
proposition de loi dans un délai parti
un parti extrêmement court au regard des
enjeux
merci madame la sénatrice
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
intervenir dans la décision générale
allez-y je vous en prie brièvement
madame la présidente
sur quelques quelques points des
questions directes qui ont pu être
posées par les différents intervenants
d'abord dire que le ségur de la santé ne
se résume pas évidemment à cette
proposition parlementaire de loi
l'immense majorité des mesures non
salariales contenu dans le secteur de la
santé sont du domaine réglementaire et
ne relèvent pas du législatif nous
permettant évidemment d'aller bien au
delà du périmètre de ce texte de loi
ensuite dire qu'il y à des ordonnances
j'ai acheté il en a été beaucoup
question je crois que c'est le sénateur
je me et qui en a parlé à plusieurs
reprises nous avons la fenêtre
d'habilitation s'étend jusqu'au 25 mars
il n'y a plus beaucoup à attendre et ses
ordonnances je le disais en discussion
en discussion générale sont actuellement
la concertation avec les acteurs
vous verrez qu'elles sont je pense
équilibré qu'elle réponde en grande
partie aux préconisations du rapport
clarisse dont je rappelle qu'il avait
été très bien accueilli ce que je
propose volontiers à madame la
présidente de la commission celle de
souhaite c'est de venir vous présenter
ces ordonnances dès qu'elles auront été
publiés devant votre commission
sénatoriale
madame la sénatrice un bain vous avez
posé une question sur le renforcement de
l'attractivité des zones sous denses
pour favoriser l'appropriation des
futurs métiers vous avez parlé notamment
de la maîtrise de stage ambulatoire on a
deux objectifs qu'ils ont pour moi
indissociables augmenter le nombre de
maîtres de stage pour parvenir à une
capacité de formation suffisante sur le
territoire et puis maintenir si
nécessaire améliorer la qualité de
l'encadrement des internes tant au plan
pédagogique qu'au plan professionnel
dans ce cadre et dans celui d'un groupe
de travail spécifique du ségur de la
santé il ya des travaux qui portent sur
la diversification des terrains de stage
parler donc des services du ministère y
travaille on veut identifier les
conditions de réalisation et de
développement de ces stages dans les
territoires dans des conditions qui
permet de garantir une exigence de
qualité de la formation
on ne peut aboutir dans les tout
prochains mois s'agissant de votre
deuxième question le décret je pensais
que j'avais mes notes le décret 2020
tirs et 9 151 du 30 juillet 2020 relatif
aux conditions de l'agrément des maîtres
de stage des universités accueillant des
étudiants de deuxième et de troisième
cycle des études de médecine a été pris
en application du iii de l'article 2 une
réponse précise et factuelle mais si
vous souhaitez en europe en compléter
quelques quelques aspects
complémentaires l'esprit du ségur s'est
pris la liberté retrouvée et durée du
retour du sens pour celles et ceux qui
font leurs missions dans une structure
type hospitalière pour ce qui concerne
la partie hospitalière l'esprit du
seigneur c'est de permettre à chacune et
à chacun de s'organiser
non pas librement on va pas transformer
l'hôpital en phalanstère mais avec des
règles mais qu'ils soient des règles
moins rigide c'est rendre finalement non
opposable est partie du code de santé
publique non pas pour ce qui concerne la
qualité ou la sécurité ou la continuité
des soins
mais pour l'organisation interne pardon
j'ai aussi une porter la blouse pendant
un certain temps
la disparition du service la
structuration en pole a eu du bon enfin
la disparition du service a été beaucoup
regretté les modalités de gouvernance
interne un discours pardon mais très dur
en 2007 du président de la république il
ya un seul patron à l'hôpital je serai
le directeur
tout ça n'est pas sans conséquences sur
l'état d'esprit qui règne depuis plus de
dix ans maintenant dans nos
établissements de santé et je dis pas
que la réforme était mauvaise je dis que
de toute façon ils les transformations
sont nécessaires au bout d'un certain
temps au bout d'un certains cycles et
quand on se rend compte que des
externalités négatives des décisions qui
ont été prises commence à l'emporter sur
les aspects positifs et donc redonner de
la souplesse dans la structuration
l'hôpital se veut pas dire c'est
certainement paraît opposer directeur et
médecins moi j'ai jamais compris ce
débat j'ai peut-être eu la chance de
jour évoluer dans des hôpitaux où le
directeur le pcm e fonctionner en binôme
ce que je crois profondément c'est que
quand on donne la possibilité aux uns et
aux autres de changer leur gouvernance
interne on apporte une solution à
beaucoup de problèmes ce qui a des maux
qui rongent l'hôpital il n'en a pas été
question de la discussion générale ce
sont les conflits interpersonnels c'est
dévastateur
c'est dévastateur la qualité de vie au
travail à l'hôpital elle passe aussi par
la capacité des uns et des autres à se
sentir entendus écoutés libres dans leur
exercice est respecté et ce qui s'est
passé pendant le co lead c'est que les
directeurs les soignants médecins
paramédicaux ont tous regardé dans une
seule direction la même soigné sauvé des
vies s'organiser il a fallu prendre des
décisions très vite elles ont été prises
il a fallu sortir du code des marchés
publics sous l'urgence sanitaire pour
pouvoir acheter de quoi fabriquer des
services d'urgence extérieur à l'hôpital
en catastrophe en 48 heures ce a pu être
fait mais dans la vie du quotidien c'est
pas ça dans la vie du quotidien c'est
pas ça et pardon de faire appel à mon
expérience un nouveau professionnel
personnel mais j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir monter un hôpital de jour on
euros logis au chu de grenoble
et je me souviens très bien c'est un
exemple parmi d'autres que comme c'était
souvent des patients jeunes atteints de
sclérose en plaques qui allait avoir une
perfusion pendant une ou deux heures
j'avais préféré plutôt qu'aux délits
avoir des fauteuils confortables
compatible avec des perfusions on
pouvait être 3 10e de trois fauteuils au
lieu de 2 10 et j'avais identifié des
fauteuils qui ne coûtait pas très cher
c'était quand même confortable donc il
coûte un peu plus d'un millier d'euros
mais qui était de nature à rendre en
plus l'espace plus accueillant et plus
moderne
et en faire vraiment un truc ambulatoire
catastrophe dans le code des marchés
publics
il y avait un livre dans lequel vous
avez un type de fauteuil trente mille
balles de fauteuils c'est ça aussi la
rigidité à l'hôpital moi je vais vous
dire une chose si j'avais pu j'aurais
même aller plus loin que les mesures qui
ont été proposées notamment en termes de
code des marchés publics mais là il ya
une législation européenne qui est très
forte en la matière il faut donner de
l'autonomie aux établissements faut pas
qu'on ait peur il faut évidemment des
règles qui encadrent les choses mais
faut pas désigner un patron du doigt en
disant c'est toi qui va être responsable
de tout le monde c'est pas vrai sa chute
grenoble ces dix mille feuilles de paye
on peut pas confier une seule
résponsabilité une seule personne quand
bien même ce serait quelqu'un d'
extrêmement dévoués et talentueux donc
il faut repenser l'organisation interne
et la gouvernance interne et ça les
éléments qui sont dans cette ppl en
répondre en partie l'autre partie l est
du domaine réglementaire
on aura l'occasion d'en débattre un
point sur les explique c'est le sénateur
dans narbonne qui en a parlé les
explique il ya des amendements que
j'avais entrevue de déposer à la ppl
mais qui ont été eux qui étaient
susceptibles de ne pas passer l'article
45 à l'assemblée nationale ça aurait été
compliqué de me faire moi-même refoulé
des amendements vous comprenez les ai
retirées donc je regarderai avec
vraiment beaucoup d'attention un certain
nombre d'amendements que vous avez
déposé avec d'autres collègues je pense
aux sénateurs iacovelli qui sont qui me
semble vraiment intéressant on aura
l'occasion d'en parler personne doit
être évidemment à bordeaux n'est oublié
et enfin vous dire sur la médecine de
ville
c'est que la médecine de ville elle
répond une organisation qui n'est pas
législatives en propre mais elle répond
aux négociations conventionnelles entre
la cnam l'unocam et les syndicats c'est
le dialogue social c'est le cadre qui a
été déterminé par la loi de 2004 et
c'est ce cadre que je respecte
évidemment donc il ya des mesures qui
concerne la médecine de ville
certaines sont déjà opérationnels
notamment en matière d'investissements
du ségur
d'autres vont avoir lieu dans le cadre
de la convention les débats avaient
commencé les discussions des échanges
ils ont été suspendus compte tenu de la
proximité des élections professionnelles
qui ne rendait pas à le cadre propice à
des conclusions d'accord ça reprendra
sitôt les élections professionnelles
passées évidemment qu'on va travailler à
l'articulation entre la médecine de
ville et l'hôpital
je me bats depuis des années pour qu'on
casse les silos entre la ville et
l'hôpital entre le médico social et
médical on a vu pendant la crise qu vide
du canton casser les silos on était plus
efficace
c'est vraiment l'objet en tout cas c'est
l'état d'esprit qui m'anime et j'arrive
à retrouver
j'allais dire mes bébés dans un certain
nombre d'articles de cette ppl auquel je
crois et je le répète c'est un travail
parlementaire que vous avez la
possibilité comme parlementaire
d'enrichir de modifier des bâtons je
remercie
[Musique]